sam get him
use the shield sam with the shoes whoa
[ __ ]
oh my god he's been training he's been
training
without a super soldiers how much power
does the power broker really have it's
true
dang
oh my gosh this doesn't really make any
sense so you're the power broker
i mean even bad trucks confused
[Music]
ah friendship it's the power of
friendship
i'll miss these guys captain america and
the winner oh
oh shoot it says captain america now
it's not falcon that's oh my god
it's a big shotgun it's on facebook
welcome back to new rock
stars the falcon in the winter soldier
episode 6 officially rebrand sam wilson
with
a closing title of captain america and
the winter soldier
so great so great responding to all the
doubt
over whether or not he should carry
captain america shield with the
brightest most colorful version of the
captain america suit
we have seen yet but uh for everything
else in this finale
really right now we can only say what
[Laughter]
this is inside marvel it's new rockstars
after show for the falcon and the winter
soldier i'm eric voss here with mt
how are you feeling mt i'm feeling so
excited
to finally see a live action black
captain america and like i didn't think
that i would get like
emotional on the inside like seeing him
fly around but i was like oh my god this
is
actually happening this is happening
this is for real so
oh man i'm feeling i'm feeling hopeful
for the future
yeah the way the way sam owns it and uh
the way he just shuts everyone down says
no i'm captain america
and like that whole every scene with
isaiah bradley on the show was so
beautiful
oh my god lumley kicks ass like he's
just such a good actor
it's so good so yeah he's fantastic all
this stuff with with sam's journey over
whether or not to carry that shield is
if it could just be that as a show a
you know like what an interesting story
uh what like an emotional journey
um but a lot of the stuff on the
periphery of the show is just leaving us
a little confused as to what the intent
was so here we're just gonna try to
go through it together because we're i'm
not here trying to crap on the show or
anything i know
writing tv editing tv especially during
a pandemic is really hard
so you have to end up making certain
compromises certain choices choosing
what your priorities are
um so i think we're just going to go
through what exactly
uh they mean by the finale this whole
scene with sharon carter who's she on
the phone with
she in there and what has been her plan
this whole time
uh i let's let's see if we can figure it
out together
let's dig into it so for episode six the
flag smashers are trying to straight up
murder the grc
it's not just disrupting carly takes it
a step further and she's like yeah i'm
gonna
drive this truck into a big um
construction pit
and they'll all die and they're like
jeez what did i sign up for
but they are stopped by bucky also
sharon carter uh a face mesh
chemical weapon sharon carter yikes
i was excited to see the face mesh again
i was like yeah that's like one of my
favorite things about winter soldier
i was excited to see the face smush when
she melted that dude
right i was like oh my god this is some
really just violent stuff like his face
was just like
yeah that's what i get for hugging
a random white lady on the street by
accident oh
never do that that's what happens when
you're doing social distance you get
your faces
right that's right it's not over yet no
hugs no
touching um but uh they're of course
also stopped most pivotably
pivotally i started gotta stop making up
words um
sam wilson uh once falcon now captain
america
in this badass new suit given to him by
the wakandans and he's now proudly going
by captain america it's so great
john walker shows up in this fight and
he ultimately chooses to save lives
instead of seeking vengeance
interesting choice there very
interesting and during this sharon
carter reveals herself
we think to be the power broker and she
kills patrick i say we think just
because
she never explicitly says it but the
context of the scene is yes
she is the power broker i'm not going to
argue that point um
and she actually also later kills carly
uh and then as sam brings carly's body
back he makes this big speech to the grc
leaders
which i love this perfect video and
audio picked up by the nearby
i know that's all i can think about i
was just like how are you getting this
perfect audio right now that's
impossible
because the whole world needs to watch
this speech whether it's uh
tori is just watching on his tv screen
or
sarah watching at home everybody's
watching this one news feed
right and basically his speech kind of
goes on and covers a lot of different
areas but he basically conveys carly's
um ideals that the people making these
decisions for the rest of the world
don't truly empathize with the struggle
of the people who are being affected by
these decisions
um it's kind of a rocky iv moment where
he's like look if i can change
and you can change maybe we all could
change
and it works somewhere gorbachev was
watching this standing up
so yes i do like this new black one yes
let's let's
do more of that um but no like i love
that speech it was just it's so true
because
a lot of the times politicians don't
consult any of the people that they're
making legislation for so it's just like
you guys need to open your eyes like
come on man like
you're trying to like effectively deport
a zillion people
to homelessness like they don't really
know where they're going so it's just
like
right sit down and think about it guys
because the flag smashers
even though they were kind of not the
most interesting villains
yeah uh and it's uh they often i think
you say politicians have to pick winners
and
uh winners and losers and they don't
think about the people who are going to
be losing
as a result of these kind of decisions
so that's true you don't have to pick
winners and losers in society you can
take a step back and kind of make things
that are going to be good for
for the and you've got to look out for
the most vulnerable of society right
that's if you're going to be making
decisions
exactly i mean i'm sure vulture would
agree with all of this you'd be like
yeah [ __ ] the government think about us
he was standing up a plotting too and
he's like and
also nice wings right
quacks in america is also flapping his
wings
saluting with his wing from that lake in
new york now uh the flag smashers this
is a little hilarious they were arrested
and immediately blown up
orchestrated by zemo through his old
butler
white gloves and all oh oh man that old
man was uh he came for the smoke he was
like you know what no
super soldiers like the the mission
still goes on even though the master
is in prison for now yep so val
suits up john walker as u.s agent zemo's
still chilling in the raft prison
sam kind of gets isaiah's blessing and
then reveals the statue of him
in the cap exhibit so his history is no
longer
as erased as it was though we were
joking before this call i think a lot of
people are going to go to that exhibit
and be like who was this one again
i'm not going to read the plaque i don't
know who that is it's like who is this
one oh it's so nice that they put the
plaque there anyway moving on
it's just like yeah there definitely
should have been more of a
more cameras and stuff there to be like
look this happened
it's a black captain america before like
you know after steve rogers
bucky fesses up to mr nakajima about
what he did to his son
and then they all party back home that's
the kind of party i can't wait to get
back into i know right the cookout bro
you invited a little cookout eric just
just so you know you're invited to the
cookout i'm still invited
even after the theories i came up with
through this show yeah cause
we need furies at the cookout how can
you can't have a cookout without some
marvel theories bro
oh thank you thank you so much um and
then
we get this uh post-credits scene where
sharon gets her pardon from apparently
the only
guy who works for the us government this
guy's pulling triple duty
um and she has this shady phone call
about now having access to government
secrets and uh
prototype weapons leaving us wonder who
she's on the phone with and what her
next steps are
so we are going to talk about sharon
carter and this power broker reveal and
also what is next for her and for
captain america uh
sam wilson captain america that is but
also old cap uh
as well as for bucky and us agent john
walker what's happening when are we
going to see all these characters again
and what's going to be their mission
uh but before we dive into it real quick
i am wearing our latest obsession shirt
anarchy assembled which you can get at
newarkstersmerch.com but but we also
just released a new zemo design who's
really pulling the strings
both designs are getting low on stock
and some sizes are close to selling out
so grab one fast before they're gone
and if you get the nrk assembled shirt
as is always the case for inside marvel
you will unlock an additional option to
write in a custom
shout out that will look here at the
bottom of these inside marvel after
shows for example let's see miguel
galvan
says how do you think the last episode
of the falcon winter soldier will
correlate with the upcoming
shang chi i had some thoughts that uh
there would be a major board connection
especially the power broker was going to
be revealed as the mandarin which she
was not um i still think shanghai could
visit madrid
though oh yeah definitely i i shang chi
i mean with your breakdown you
definitely hit the nail on the head
there like that fight
seems to be taking place in madrid and i
was doing some research the other day
and i believe that fight
was a fight called the bloodsport in
madrid oh yeah um it happens once a year
um so yeah i think that we're going to
see shengshi
in madrid at some point uh another
comment see jedediah herrera says if
bucky married sarah then he and sam
would be stuck together for life
that's true i am shipping those too hard
i want to see yes
i just want bucky to marry sarah just to
spite sam i just think that
would just be hilarious they have to
spend every thanksgiving together
i'm sorry i need to see them in each
other's lives
it's like where's uncle buck
[Laughter]
uh and robert cutler says gma cannon
eric vos cannon
new obsession shirt cannon i'm canon yep
i uh 100 agree
that's accurate logic eric is 100 canon
um
in in real life and the mcu and the gma
cannon
well they're gonna fire me out of a
cannon now after all this
oh lordy lordy um all right mt what's
our first what the falcon
well the first what the falcon of the
day eric is how the falcon is sharing
card in the power broker all right i
gotta take the l
here um because i'm not gonna hide i'm
not gonna i'm gonna take the l with you
bro you're not taking the l alone i will
take the l with you because i was right
here with you when you when we were
saying it bro
i appreciate that uh i firmly did not
believe sharon carter was herself the
power broker i was thinking maybe she
was working for the power broker instead
it was
i thought maybe it was connected to the
ten rings um or
some other shadowy crime lord but
instead this episode
proves me wrong as i've been proved
wrong by pretty much every movie i have
made predictions for
people were joking saying like oh eric's
oh for two it's like no no my friend
i've been doing this for like five years
i'm like uh like 100 for 350 maybe
still not a good record that i'm not
proud of but
uh i'm not in this for accuracy
obviously
with the theories i pitched um but just
like kind of the most fun ways i think
this might go based off
listen you're talking with one of the
most wrong people
on the internet me like i have been so
wrong about guardians of the galaxy
stuff in the past
so like next to me you're you're
perfectly fine dude don't worry about it
we're just sharing a debunked bed we've
been debunked
and we trade off top and bottom of
debunk
that's just how it works um so what did
this episode kind of explain with sharon
carter
uh we get this moment with carly
morgenthau where sharon wants carly to
come work for her again none of the
other people are around it's just the
two of them it seems uh but then carly
starts to say sharon only wants her for
power and how much power does a power
broker have without her
uh and sharon kind of gives this
interesting kind of look and says well
more than you
and then batrock overhears this and says
ah so you're the people
broke out and then uh he says that he's
gonna
uh threaten to tell the whole world
about this unless he pays her four times
as much
uh and then sharon's like i don't like
blackmail and then shoots him
killing him and then later uh you know
hides
covers us up by shooting and killing
carly and then at the end the episode
sharon gets her pardon but then shadily
calls her contacts to be ready for state
secrets and prototype weapons
so who do you think sharon is calling
here maybe one of her lieutenants maybe
another criminal contact
uh could she be calling people i mean
honestly
it seems like she's connected to
everybody who's uh who wants
weapons in the mcu whether it be the ten
rings uh
aim justin hammer's old organization his
contacts just hammer yourself
um if a norman osborne ever gets
introduced to the mcu he's probably
going to be on the rolodex of uh
of the power broker i mean i i honestly
think that the show
is establishing her as the power broker
and like you said even though we haven't
explicitly gotten
um her saying yes i am the power broker
i'm sharon power broker carter you can
just call me
sharon secrets because that's just what
i'd be doing um
but we haven't got that exactly but i i
i would be hard-pressed to think that
they would end the series as being like
oh no she wasn't really the power broker
it seems like she is the power broker
and she was talking to one of her
underlings um just be like hey get ready
because uh i just got pardoned and i'm
about to get my old job back so like i'm
about to you know snitch on all these
people
yeah um so yeah i just think that she
was just talking to a random associate
yeah i agreed mt um a lot of folks out
there are saying like well maybe she
isn't actually the true power broker
because
um you know she never explicitly says
she's the power broker
no i mean i part of me wishes that were
the case but here's the big
glaring evidence she killed bad truck
over his threat to tell the world that
she's a power broker and by killing him
she proves that she must be the true
power broker because she needs to stay
anonymous
that's her the big source of her power
is her anonymity
she wouldn't have killed uh bad truck
she wouldn't have cared if that truck
thought she was a power broker
if she wasn't the true power broker
right she would have just called us
blood and said go ahead tell who you
want
i'm definitely not that powerful it's
like you're wrong but like whatever
it'll help the real power broker if you
just spread that around so whatever
i think it would help to go back through
this season try to track what sharon
carter's plan has been throughout all
this
as a power broker um so looking at it
uh stepping back from it as a power
broker sharon must know that
her greatest power comes from anonymity
so she's been
claiming that she might work for the
power broker she's at least in his orbit
but all this time all along she was
secretly her own boss
self-employed this one um but we have to
ask how long has sharon been the power
broker
because zemo said that he was aware of
him only by reputation
and seemed to have run afoul of the
power broker in the past
the problem is zemo has been in prison
this whole time
um and uh he was in prison since civil
war and during in civil war sharon
carter seemed to be just working for the
cia she had not broken bad yet
so shane carter might have had a double
identity as a power broker way back then
but also based on her line to sam and
bucky in episode three this whole life
of crime didn't really start until she
was labeled a criminal
in civil war and then had to leave the
country so it's not really clear when
this began it seems like the show is
saying this was relatively recently it
was sometime after civil war
i was thinking that there could
potentially be a possibility
that maybe a power broker existed some
like in some time before
sharon went on the run and then sharon
deposed of the power broker
and because no one knew what the power
broker looked like she could be like oh
i can just be the power broker now
because it's easy because no one knows
what he looks like
i like that idea that is a possibility
but yeah but we don't really know at
this point in time yeah as the power
broker sharon carter wants to wield
influence via things like the super
soldier serum but also
other valuable assets like stolen art
prototype weapon state secrets but in
order to do that
she has to be able to fly under the
radar and ideally she needs to be back
in the united states in her old job at
the cia with all the contacts and
information she had at her disposal
so sharon at some point in the past
hired carly andovich to work security
for her in madrid
to protect her interests in the super
soldier serum project but they ended up
stealing that serum
so as she tried to track down carly sam
and bucky and zemo arrived
looking for the same thing so sharon
must have seen an opportunity to use
these guys to help her find carly
and ultimately get her pardon out of
that deal um but then in order to do
that sharon had to kill
selby that was that rival crime leader
in madrapore because selby was about to
kill sam
who would have been her ticket to a
pardon and then she ended up killing
many of the assassins triggered by
selby's death
all while sam and bucky talked to dr
nagel
now the implication of that is sharon
actually didn't really need to find dr
nagle's location using those contacts at
the art party she would have known full
where
well where he was throughout all of that
it was all smoking mirrors it was all
the show
she just wanted to see zemo dance she
was like that's what it was all about
he's like i need to see this guy dance
first then we can get to my master plan
right um but first we dance and then
later sharon uses
uh some power broker satellites let's
not forget about those to help save and
[ __ ] find carly while steering clear
of john walker but
we have to acknowledge that this reveal
left us with quite a few
questions yes like why did sharon carter
lead sam bucky and zemo
to nagel if she wanted to collaborate to
find the flag smashers
couldn't she have just told them what
she as a power broker already knew
about the flag smashers past whereabouts
or maybe use her satellites
like why would she expose her precious
chemist
to someone like zemo exactly that's a
those are really good questions i think
yeah i think she's just really just
trying to just keep that power broker
thing a secret and she was just like you
know what i'm not the power broker see
here's nagel like don't even consider me
right um
right but there are other ways you know
but um
this is just what they end up doing and
also if she's a power broker
why didn't she have any backup while
facing the assassins in those shipyards
like if this was all an act who was it
for
sam and bucky were inside they were not
watching her in that moment
she was going at it alone on all these
guys despite having a criminal empire of
armed people
to take down but she was going alone to
do this
yeah i mean she as a power broker she
must have
uh an army of people we saw her
militants that she checked in with
in that channel uh last episode of the
episode before why weren't any of them
why didn't you have any backup
maybe uh one of sharon carter's uh new
uh powers as the power broker is that
she can uh
see when the audience is watching and so
she was like i have to put on a show for
everyone because they're gonna find that
all the power bro yeah i gotta fool
those new rock stars nerds
to look like idiots
are watching we gotta kill them
accomplished um
but furthermore i mean we have to
address how could sharon have built up
this empire
in this limited amount of time i mean
in-game said she blipped
i know a lot of folks are arguing with
me on twitter saying that that missing
person screen could have been faked
and that jared carter was faking her
dusting um
maybe that's the truth now i think the
show's ultimate answer to all of these
questions
is that's just how badass sharon carter
is
like this is someone who can fool the
avengers into thinking she dusted
fool the criminal world into thinking
she's some into thinking there's some
other power broker man behind the
curtain who's not her
all while she builds a criminal empire
with hundreds of millions of dollars in
stolen artwork
along with satellites super soldier
serum chemical weapons that melt people
black widow face mask mesh and the
ability to
get into the us undetected all while
single-handedly john wicking
through dozens of assassins um
i hate it maybe she is just that good i
don't know but
she literally she must be that good
batman effect
in some weird way it's just like i'm
just a human
like tank and like i can just do
anything it just yeah it's
kind of weird that is the truth that
it's weird but it's true apparently
and i could try to chalk this up to all
the reshoots and re-edits they clearly
did on the show because
yeah we've talked about this all these
scenes with sharon carter and the flag
smashers
just seemed super rushed uneven weirdly
edited and i do that to compare them to
all the other
really good stuff in the show like
everything was sam's journey with the
shield
isaiah bradley so well written so well
edited
this is what these same tv producers are
capable of doing when
they're telling the story that they want
to tell just come re-watch it and
compare the scenes with the flag
smashers and just look how fast
all this exhibition exposition drops how
inelegantly
they drop what their next step or what
their mission is
uh it's you can get away with a little
bit of that in tv shows but if you have
to do it this much it means stuff was
changed
and i am dying to hear what the show
runners say was the original plan or
what they
intended the flag smashers and sharon
carter to be all about
it would be so great to get like a like
a full-length documentary of both like
one division and falcon in the winter so
yeah just to see just how much uh covert
19 just
messed things up because yeah it really
did they had that bts documentary for
um for one division on disney plus but
they don't go
too deep into what was changed because
that's kind of like they don't want to
go too much into how the sausage gets
made
because it kind of exposes how hard this
all is
and how many sacrifices have to get made
and ultimately i think and they're right
that
general viewers don't care that much
about it but that is changing now with
things like the snyder cut
the narrative of justice league in 2017
was what was changed what was supposed
to be in this
until years later we get the original
intent with the original vision of what
this was supposed to be
and for better or worse that's the world
we live in now
um i'm not crazy about that but
that's like when you change this much
and you have this kind of weird
finished product with this subplot
people are going to have questions
it's inevitable yeah i there could be a
huge virus subplot that had to be
removed leaving everyone connected to
that subplot now weirdly confusing and
finished edit
um but i do have to say by capping this
series with the post-credits scene
that shows intent that means the
producers are saying this is what they
all
wanted it to build up to in that
post-credits scene with sharon
like i'm i'm now trying to wonder what
they were setting
up with that they didn't have to include
that post-credits scene we were it was
already pretty clear that sharon was the
power broker
that you know you could have included
her pardon scene in the midst of that
closing montage
but with that post credit scene there
seemed to be a couple different
things that it could be setting up i
mean like it could potentially be
setting up
sharon as a villain in armor wars yeah
that's what i was thinking too
yeah because we were talking about that
earlier and you brought that up i was
like yeah he's totally right
yeah i mean this is uh a lot of people
are saying secret invasion that she
might be a scroll but
if anything this makes it less likely
she's a scroll to me because she used
that mask
to hide her identity if she was a
squirrel shape-shifter she would not
mess around with that kind of tech it'd
be like beneath her
she could shape-shift into anything if
she was an
actual skrull not saying she won't be in
secret invasion she could totally show
up in secret invasion
i just don't think she's gonna be
playing the role of scrolls she's now
gonna be playing this role of
vague power broker and that's what she
is in the mcu now
it's the new trevor slattery in a way
yeah but i do think armor wars is where
we'll see her next just because this
idea of prototype weapons i think that's
what it's gonna be fought over roadie's
gonna be part of that
um and we're gonna see it's gonna be the
war
of superhero technology you know when
things that are derived from tony
stark's tech falling into the wrong
hands
which i would argue has been the story
of the whole mcu up until this point
but um uh we're gonna just see a true
rhodey led story about that i think
sharon is now looking like gonna be the
villain of armor wars if i wonder
sharon is gonna gun after white vision
now because white vision is
loose uh element and now that she's you
know stealing secrets she's gonna know
that white vision is on the loose
and go to try to go get him probably
yeah
who knows yeah white vision might be the
ultimate macguffin of armor wars
like they're trying to convince white
vision to fight on their side to fight
on their side there's gonna be a lot of
different people who are making
uh ship based metaphors to him to try to
convince him to join their team
like so i hear you like shipbuilding huh
well look at
this and it's gonna be like the napoleon
dynamite scenes like i bet you ain't
seen one of these before
it's like i want it's like oh hey vision
have you ever heard of the nina pinta
and santa maria those are some pretty
great ships
recalibrating tell me changing
allegiances
uh we'll be talking far more about
sharon carter
as time goes on but there are more
questions we want to get to from the
show but first we want to thank some
people who helped us make this
starting with our friends at bespoke
post bespoke post has a new lineup of
essential box of awesome collections for
guys guaranteed to upgrade your life the
retreat box comes with a cool hammock
which is perfect for the spring because
by the time you get into the outdoors
you will be ready for a nap
uh whether or not you're uh out taming
the wilderness or taking
uh your home bar to pro level heights
bespoke post only sends guys the best
stuff every month
no matter what you're into box of
awesome has you covered from style and
grooming goods to bar
wear cooking tools and outdoor gear box
of awesome has collections for every
part of your life
to get started take the quiz at
boxingbostom.com your answers will help
them pick the right box of awesome for
you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
the brew and flight boxes are the new
ones that look really cool to me
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel any time each box only
costs 45 bucks but has over 70 dollars
worth of gear inside
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at boxingboston.com and
enter the code marvel at check out
that's box of awesome dot com
code marvel for 20 off your first box
also we want to thank our princeton
upstart so paying off debt can feel like
an uphill battle
high interest rates resulting in minimum
monthly payments keeps you in an endless
cycle of debt
well upstart can help you get ahead
upstart is the fast and easy way off
your debt with a personal
loan all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over
half a million people have used upstart
to get a simple fixed monthly payment
unlike other lenders upstart looks at
more than just your credit score like
your income
and employment history this means they
can offer smarter rates
with trusted partners with a five minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans between
one thousand to fifty thousand dollars
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day
after accepting your loan find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to upstart.com
marvel that's upstart.com marvel don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we sent you
load amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided on your loan
application
go to upstart.com marvel and lastly we
want to thank betterhelp for sponsoring
us
lots of us have gone through periods
where something was interfering with our
happiness or preventing us from
achieving our goals right
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating with them in under 48
hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help
it is professional counseling done
securely online it's available worldwide
and includes a broad range of expertise
that
may not be available in your area you'll
get a
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in
an uncomfortable waiting room as you
would with traditional therapy
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today
join the over 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
they have a special offer for our
audience get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
marvel that's better
h-e-l-p dot com marvel for 10
off your first month all right empty our
next what the falcon i want to know from
you
what the falcon was val's involvement
with zemo
and his butler's killing of the flag
smashers she was kind of teasing
that she was involved with it wasn't
involved with it but was
do you think she had a hand in that but
potentially i mean i feel like they
wouldn't put that line in there if she
didn't have something to do with it
and you know she was very with like she
was very quick to pick up like oh
this explosion happened zemo this is emo
it's straight up zemo
so maybe she provided uh she worked in
conjunction with zemo's butler to
provide him with the explosives or
something
to make it happen or um you know maybe
she is
trying to put this thunderbolts team
together yeah so like she's like all
right
i'll do a little something for zemo zema
does a little something for me you know
and like it's it's in everyone's best
interest to have the flag smashers dead
anyway so you know i'm sure she didn't
she wasn't sad if she was involved to do
it but
it's sort of still up in the air what do
you think eric yeah i don't see why she
would uh
i mean at first i could see why she
would want to take credit for that but
just to john walker's
wife you know like what is she trying to
prove yeah i think she was
involved with it in a way i think uh i
think she helped
because i don't think that butler could
have planned that all by himself like
i'm sorry i know zemo has resources and
this butler
is like on his own private jet his
outfit i like to think that
he only just like serves zemo does
crosswords and then plans explosions
i do three things really well what you
need me to do explosions today no
nose alfred zalfried just the jet today
it's like oh he puts the bombs away
sadly puts bombs away
um yeah so that's why i think i think
val was involved with that i think
i wanted to see a conversation between
val and zemo on the raft there
just to kind of tie that together but as
off-screen producer brandon said
it seemed like they had julie lily
dreyfus for one day and then just shot
both her scenes
in that location with those other two
actors that's all they had to hurt
but i think you're right i think that we
could still be seeing something
thunderbolts related
if there was that link between val and
uh and with zemo
on the raft something overseen by
thaddeus ross someone who showed up in
the credits of the show but
wasn't at all referenced otherwise in
the show why
why did you put him in the credits yeah
that's such a weird
thing because it's like everything else
in the credits pretty much came up
isaiah bradley came up power broker came
up all these other little clues in the
credits came up i wonder if he
either he was cut or his role was cut
maybe and that he pro
maybe he had a bigger role in like the
you know if cove had never happened
cut of this but yeah it is super weird
to have
him his name brought up at all all right
third what the falcon of the day is
what the falcon is next for john walker
as us agent i mean like are we supposed
to like him now because it was sort of
random
that like you know we sort of ended the
last episode with like
i'm crazy and i'm about to do some crazy
things to avenge lamar
and now he's just sort of just like i
guess we're buddying up with the people
that broke my arm i guess this is
fine he's quoting lincoln uh right
and saving he got quotes like up while
he was making his new
wack shield yeah like i just it's just
really weird
that like they just it seems to me that
they were just like
we're setting john walker up for
something else so we can't make him look
super crazy and super unlikable and you
know like
like a villain because we sort of want
to set him up as u.s agent
as this sort of like you know like
well-meaning captain america
quote-unquote
um but with like some you know
everything not all
right up there yeah i think that's the
problem though with that is like
that scene with him bludgeoning that
dude of death with the shield
is one of the more striking images from
this show and you need to tell us that
we're supposed to now empathize with
that character after that and like him
now and see
like obviously he's gonna be more of an
anti-hero but that moment at the end
where he goes i'm back i'm back i'm back
there was no judgment to that scene i i
mean all we know is that he's just
working with val
but it seems like the show's moral
conclusions
were cloudy at best when it comes to
characters like john walker
and carly morgenthau like yeah carly's
own
flag smashers turned on her and said
whoa you a
freaking crazy terrorist and then like
at the end sam cradles her body just
because she says she's sorry
and then argues with all these senators
the senators suck too i get it
argue with them i think his speech was
justified to them
but i mean i'm just worried about the
bad takes out there where people are
going to be like wait so you're saying
we're allowed to disrupt
a vote by government leaders and
senators
and we're not terrorists if we do that
and we throw
uh smoke bombs in a government building
and try to kill them
that's okay as long as our ideals as
long as we're the victims of the
situation
i mean yeah i don't like the way that
was written at all
yeah because like you're totally right
because like they
technically sort of got what they wanted
through violence in a way like they
their voices were heard
and then you know you know through sam
the grc
stepped down so it's just like what
message are we sending here is are we
saying like violence works
and like it's okay to like you know
attack the grc
if you need to um even though the grc
isn't real but you know it's just like
what what i don't understand
specifically it's okay to try to murder
them it's okay to try to burn them alive
and
run their truck off a freaking uh
edge into a ravine like it's okay to do
that
yeah it's just like it's just really
weird just like you know
the flag smashers technically won with
with their
um wanting to be heard through extremism
and it's just like
it's what's going to stop the next
person from being you know
putting up the mask and becoming a flag
smasher or
some type of other extremists like zemo
or or you know
to be fair to sam into this show that is
a point sam makes in a speech he does
say like you don't want to see what the
next version of carly morgan that was
going to look like
i totally get and the mcu is okay to
have us empathize with the
sentiment or the philosophy of the
villains as we saw with
killmonger black panther did such a good
job of that uh
with thanos like a lot of people were
saying theodos did nothing wrong but
like
they kind of present this malthusian
argument with thanos that like the ends
justify the means
with thanos as well with zemo but here
her
mission has always been kind of
different episode to episode you don't
really know
why she's doing what she's doing other
than i'm the little guy
they're making decisions that aren't
good for us but like
then she murders people as a result of
it and then we get these looks of
judgment from her own team
and like you include that scene where a
team looks like they're about to kill
her right there
looks like they're about to just like
push her off that ledge to be like i
don't want to fight
alongside this person anymore and then
sam pretty much validates
all of her actions and her entire
argument
and i just don't i think that part of
his speech
was like ooh move on move on sam move on
um like maybe we should talk about this
let's just keep let's keep talking about
like
moving on but this same thing with john
walker though like it's even worse in
that case because he is
a character who murdered someone in the
street and they kind of punished him
last episode but he says i'm back he
looks like someone who hasn't learned
anything
in that final scene uh he he looks like
he's rewarded
um for what he's done just because he
in the in the heat of battle he decides
not to get vengeance and decides to save
a bunch of people to me that is not
enough moral redemption for a character
after what we've seen him do
yeah and like we don't really get any
like all that much
audience shots of him showing up to the
battle and like you know he was there
when you know sam was doing his speech
and he didn't say anything like
he obviously really wanted to be captain
america but like there was no
resistance there's no pushback there was
no conversation about that
and like we only really see um
like the only person that really reacts
to this whole john walker situation is
is his wife at the very end of the
episode it's like
this is like the the lens that we're
supposed to be viewing john walker isn't
like oh no he's getting redemption
because like you know his wife seems to
be happy with him and like he seems to
be happy that he's back but just like
wha what i don't know like what are we
what is going on here i don't know um
and
you know these are gripes that we have
overall the the thematic core of the
show was following sam
in his like meeting with isaiah bradley
and if you loved this show and he loved
that part of it
we could 100 agree i think that has been
so great it's just
these are just big things on the
periphery that the show also included
that
just were not written as well and i have
a feeling that like
malcolm spellman who worked on the show
who's the writer of it didn't
necessarily want to tell those other
stories just want to tell sam's story
needed that's why he did such a great
job with it
whereas these other things were just
kind of uh marching orders from the
studio like
we need to have us agent in this i want
to have the flag smashers in this i want
to have
uh you know sharon carter in this and
then spellman was probably like all
[Laughter]
um i right that's so if you want to like
the show we don't want to take that away
from you
i just feel like the only way you can
truly truly
uh love this show without any kind of
reservations is to have some kind of
blinders on
uh and we would be lying to you if we
said that the show is perfect
you know because it's it's not a perfect
show uh
yeah it's definitely not perfect it's
it's it's definitely a good time to
watch and like i
like you know we all enjoy a new mcu
thing we're all
nuts about the marvel cinematic universe
but we gotta just keep it real we're not
gonna [ __ ] you guys like
it's not a hundred percent perfect and
there are flaws yeah
so you know i think if there's value in
in seeing those flaws in like talking
about them because it's not perfect
but it's okay because we understand that
there were those covert 19
limitations right and it's just a weird
time so the fact that we even got
a falcon in the winter soldier at all um
is a blessing
so it's true we're not talking about
keep in mind that's a very good point
um we're definitely not hating on it but
like it's it's not perfect
and uh and to that point uh
empty our final wtf that we'll talk
about in this show
where do you think we will see cap sam
and bucky
go next i mean i don't mean cap comma
sam and bucky there's no comment there
it's just like captain america sam i
want to see
yes like what uh what mcu title are they
gonna come back in
hmm i can see them maybe you know
hitting rhodey up with like the hey
thanks for cameo in my show we're going
to cameo with uh armor wars now real
quick
um just to like with that sharon carter
connection
maybe sam and bucky be like hmm what's
this power broker up to like what's
going on with like they're selling
secrets and like what's
going on so maybe then but like you know
gosh that's a really good question what
do you think what do you think they're
gonna show up um
i'd be surprised if they showed up in
any of the titles that are announced
so far um like secret invasion already
has a pretty big cast
and i think one lesson learned we have
from both this show
and from um and from one division
is that these marvel disney plus shows
are only gonna do
so much to interconnect with the mcu
right so like we can have our big
theories of how this is going to set up
multiverse of madness or thor love and
thunder or whatever
ultimately there's still kind of a
dividing line
maybe less of one than was there for
agents of shield or for the defenders
universe on netflix
but there still is one there they have
the same actors
and uh but the people who are writing it
have different priorities different
narrative priorities
that different stories that they're
telling so to answer the question
i think we will see them next in like a
young avengers
story uh i think they'll draw on the
relationship that sam started to form
with eli bradley
uh and the way that sam kind of just
like was an isolated cameo in ant-man
uh i think we'll see that again bucky um
might show up in secret invasion but
again secret invasion it's a pretty big
cast already
uh i don't think we'll see everyone in
the mcu in that and
maybe armor wars as you said but yeah i
think we're gonna have to wait to see
until there is a new like currently
unannounced marvel title that these
people will show up in
bucky maybe in black panther too that'd
be kind of fun to bring it back to
wakanda that'd be super
super appropriate uh because like she
does say uh io i mean
does say to make yourself scarce for a
little bit so i feel like you know he
will come back eventually just to be
like hey guys it's me it's your white
buddy
i'm back in africa to hang out with my
people um
let me tell you about this cool cooking
i went to i'm just kidding
but yeah you're totally right he could
totally show up as the white wolf
because i do want him to see
i want i want to see the white wolf in
action so badly
so black panther 2 would be perfect for
bucky that theory video that you put out
a couple weeks ago about like what
bucky's secret what content history was
was so cool and i want to see that as a
movie if you haven't watched the video
yet viewer go check that out you got a
white wolf in the war dogs of wakanda
let's get it kevin feige let's get it
um well that is it for this episode of
inside marvel this uh falcon winter
soldier after show but we're not done
talking about the show obviously
first off we're gonna do a q a with our
listeners on stereo
uh and that video will come out on the
channel early next week and we're also
going to have
future episodes of inside marvel next
friday
you're going to hear us talk about all
the other loose ends of the show we're
going to give ourselves like a week to
think about it to digest it
and do a postseason wrap-up question to
answer any further questions you have
going to any other theories that we
might have for some of these questions
uh so but we want to thank you guys so
much for staying with us it's been
a wild ride on this show a lot of great
moments to talk about and we're so glad
that
we were here with you and empty i it was
an honor to host this with you and i
can't wait to continue
posting bro likewise like watching the
falcon of water soldier with you
specifically has been so much fun you
are so smart
and like getting to trade insight with
you has been such a joy
it's been so much fun yeah and
especially again like with erickson with
you guys like
it's so cool getting to talk to you guys
every stereo and via youtube and all
this stuff you guys
are what makes marvel amazing i'm like
just being a nerd amazing so like you
guys
those are claps for you i love you guys
um
all right so uh follow mt at
mastertainment follow me at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to inside marvel
wherever you get your podcast again
check out all of our merch options at
nyrockstartsmerch.com
uh thank you for watching and uh we will
close with our favorite moment of the
[Music]
episode
[Music]
you